сьогодні 9 вересня 2022 року весь світ
втретє відзначає міжнародний день
захисту освіти від нападів
цей день має на меті привернути увагу до
становища мільйонів дітей які живуть в
країнах що постраждали від війни
до нападів на учнів вчителів до
руйнування закладів освіти під час
збройних конфліктів а також до
важливості зусиль спрямованих на
підтримку та захист права на освіту та
сприяння продовженню навчання під час
збройного конфлікту
втім вочевидь питання захисту освіти від
нападів мають підніматися щоденно
за міжнародними даними кожна шоста
дитина в світі проживає на територіях
охоплених збройними конфліктами і зараз
діти більше зазнають ризику конфлікту
ніж будь-коли за останні 20 років адже
понад 71 мільйон дітей віком до 5 років
живуть на території де Збройні конфлікти
тривають впродовж усього їхнього життя
станом на сьогодні через жорстку збройну
агресію Російської Федерації проти
України загинуло 383 дитини
742 дитини поранено за даними юнісеф
більше ніж як 5 мільйонів дітей в
Україні потребують гуманітарної допомоги
оскільки вони продовжують страждати від
смертельних наслідків жорсткої війни
масштабна війна Росії проти нашої країни
змусила кожного з нас переосмислити
значення
рівнодоступності та безпечної освіти у
2019 році Україна стала сотою країною
світу яка приєдналася до декларації про
безпеку шкіл та розпочала її
імплементацію
але день в день Росія жорстко порушує
положення цього документу
українська освіта постійно страждає від
звіз-агресора
російські війська продовжують вбивати
мирне населення ракетні удари та бомби
руйнують наші міста знищуються освітня
інфраструктура станом на сьогодні
внаслідок обстрілів там бомбардувань
пошкоджено
2472 заклади освіти з яких 286 повністю
зруйновані
попри все маючи постійно загрозу від
ворога Україна залишається твердо
відданою положенням декларації про
безпеку шкіл та вказівкам щодо її
виконання а також Ми продовжуємо
імплементацію національного плану дій Ми
свідомі що саме уряди країни є
відповідальними за забезпечення
конституційного права дітей на освіту та
відіграють провідну роль у здійсненні
захисту та допомоги всім дітям і молоді
які постраждали від збройних конфліктів
незважаючи на воєнний стан життя і
здоров'я дітей та всіх учасників
освітнього процесу є найвищою цінністю
для Міністерства освіти і науки України
та всього українського суспільства
команда Міністерства освіти і науки
разом з іншими центральними органами
виконавчої влади органами місцевого
самоврядування керівниками закладів
освіти всіма освітянами і батьками
робить все можливе аби кожна дитина мала
безперешкодний доступ до освіти А
навчання проходило в максимально
безпечних умовах Я вірю що весь
демократичний світ поділяє ці
переконання і вживатиме всіх можливих
кроків щоб зупинити агресора тримаємось
ми сильні ми Україна Разом до перемоги
Слава Україні